الامير هاري صار عنوان رئيسي من عناوين
البرنامج لانه على ما يبدو القناه باللي
عم يفجرها ما عم بتخلص قبل يومين من اصدار
كتابه
بعده مستمر في تصريحاته الناريه وفضائح
العائله الملكيه فمن يومين شفنا كيف فضح
الدنيا وقال انه عائلته ما بدها اياه وان
هو عم يبحث عن عائله مش عن مؤسسه بس اليوم
تجاوز الموضوع لحد هيدا امير هذه صرح عن
هذا جسدي ومعناوي صدوق صاصك بيقول انه
تعرض للضرب من اخوه ويليام في عام 2019
وانه خلال المشتركه
وسقط على الارض وعلى الطعام الكلب اللي
انكسر تحت ظهره
هاري وتسبب له بجروح وخدوش وانه الامير
ويليام وصف زوجته
ما خبر زوجته باللي صار ولكن هي اكتشفت
الجروح على صادوق ولكن لما نخبرها قال انه
هي ما تفاجات ولا حتى انصدمت طبعا الطاسه
تفاصيل راح نعرفها همم جميعا في الكتاب
راح يصدر يوم الاحد والظاهر انه راح يخرب
الدنيا ببريطانيا وفجر الامير هاري مفاجاه
الثانيه بانه اقول ملك تشارلز لما ولدت
الاميره ديانا هاري اخبر حرثيا انه الان
انجبت له ولي العهد والاحتياطي وبالتالي
انجزت عمله يعني مصر الامير هاري على انه
هو الشخص الاحتياطي في العائله المالكي
وهذا السبب كما هو متوقع لتسميه كتابه
بهذا الاسم والبعض بيقول انه هذا اللقب
الاحتياطي تسبب له عقده نفسه
[موسيقى]